hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and in my previous
video I talked about the latest dark
developments in the mha manga and how
all of this could be related to the
messed up truth about deku's father and
his secret identity I said this as we
saw literally thousands of mutant Quirk
users begin rebelling against the hero
society and supporting the villains
especially spinner you guys really seem
to like my take on deku's Dad and how
all of this could be related to the big
deku's father reveal and there were a
ton of comments asking more questions
about deku's Dad and talking about new
theories and just asking me to talk more
about it so in this video I will break
down all the latest events in the mha
manga and how it all potentially relates
to deku's father so let's get into it
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
Boku no hero videos leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it helps helps with that
crazy YouTube algorithm and over 50 of
you guys who watch my videos are not
subscribed that means that you are
watching this video right now but you
may not see my future videos and you may
miss a bunch of them so please do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications
subscribing is completely free but it is
a direct and important way of supporting
the channel finally this video will
contain Boku hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the last few chapters of
the manga the focus has been on
discrimination against mutant Quirk
users also known as heteromorphs and
their Rebellion against the hero Society
under the leadership of spinner ah it's
actually all a part of all for one
secret plan to trick all heteromorphs
into supporting the villains all
everyone knows that if he can turn a
large number of these people against the
heroes it will be that much easier for
the villains to defeat the already
outnumbered Heroes and so he is
manipulating spinner and the anger of
all the heteromorphs for his own gain
and he might even be in the process of
turning spinner into a Mindless puppet
into a no move but these last few
chapters have also stressed the fact
that there are mutant Quirk users who
support the heroes or are heroes
themselves there are heteromorphs in
high ranking positions inside the police
there are heteromorphs who are heroes
and we have heteromorph hero students in
class 1a itself including meso Shoji and
Koji Koda and as the latest chapter
demonstrates there are heteromorphs
working as doctors and nurses and
caregivers at the very hospital that the
villain mutant Quirk users are attacking
we left off last time with Shoji using
his octoarms to create one giant arm
that will be able to deliver a massive
punch directly at Godzilla spinner at
the same time Koda squirks seem to be
Awakening as sharp horns began to grow
out of the top of his head we know that
quirks get stronger with each generation
meaning that the current class 1a
students are already stronger than
members of previous generations were at
their age so we can expect a lot from
them in this battle despite the fact
that they are still just students and
speaking of quirks and Quirk potential
we then see a quick flashback in which
coda's mother explains to him that once
his horns manifest he will be able to
reach even those animals that are far
away this means that he will have access
to a much wider and more diverse pool of
animals whenever he uses his Quirk and
these animals will heed his call to help
him whenever he finds himself in a tough
spot during the flashback we also see
that koda's Dad was not a heteromorph
but he always defended his wife when
people bullied her because of her
appearance and her horns honestly huge
shout out to kota's Dad for being such a
good dude and for standing up for his
family mad respect he has proved that
even though there are many cruel humans
out there there are many others who are
kind and loving and brave I'd like to
think that the ones who are kind and
loving are in the majority but maybe I'm
just an optimist we then see present
Mike kodai and Shoji using their attacks
on the villains at the same time Coda
calls his new attack Hitchcock birds as
a huge number of birds including like
big eagles and stuff attacked the plf
commander this is of course a reference
to the movie The Birds by Alfred
Hitchcock a movie in which flocks of
birds starred ominously attacking humans
for his part Shoji calls his new attack
octo expansion and he manages to deliver
a powerful blow to spinner that actually
smashes through his kales after
delivering this attack Shoji calls out
to all the heteromorphs gathered there
and he asks them not to let Revenge
consume them if they attack innocent
people now then the cycle of violence
will continue and one day their children
will become targets too as the people
who they harm today seek revenge against
them and it will just go on and on and
on but that is when spinner seems to
regain his senses and he tells everyone
that they must fight now otherwise
Society will never change even when the
heteromorphs used to quietly hide in the
shadows and just mind their own business
they were still bullied and harassed and
attacked and sprayed with pesticide so
spinner commands his followers to stay
the course and to continue their attack
and he leaps off a building and makes
his way directly to the hospital now I'm
not 100 sure if this is the real spinner
now or if he is being manipulated by all
for one to say these things because in
the last few chapters spinner could
barely put two words together and now
he's some somehow giving a motivational
speech for his troops we'll have to wait
and see how much of this is Spinner and
how much of it is actually all for one
spinner then manages to break into the
hospital and his ultimate goal is to
locate and liberate kurogiri who is
apparently located in the research
Towers section of the building before
this battle all for one told spinner
that kurogiri's Quirk is instrumental to
winning this war for the villains so he
absolutely must be located
spinner also has to play a recording of
either all for ones or shigaraki's voice
when he reaches kurogiri and this will
activate kurogiri's Quirk kurogiri's
Quirk will then be able to liberate
shigaraki all for one from his
confinement on the UA grounds and with
all of his quirks at his disposal
shigaraki slash all for one will be able
to end the war at least that's the plan
spinner seems committed to succeeding in
this Mission and he believes that this
is what will make him a hero well he
wants to be a hero for shigaraki and his
friends and he wants to be a hero for
all the heteromorphs he wants to finally
become someone who matters someone like
his Idol stain but as spinner makes his
way through the hospital he sees the
doctors and nurses holding hands and
blocking his path to the patient Tower
section of the hospital where all the
sick patients are currently located
among these doctors and nurses we also
see heteromorphs who are putting their
lives on the line along with everyone
else to protect their hospital and their
patients the doctors and nurses are
united in their commitment to protect
their patients regardless of what they
look like or what kind of Quirk they
possess and this powerful sight moves
the villain heteromorphs who are
following behind spinner now spinner
simply bypasses the hospital staff and
heads to the research Tower where he
knows that he will find kurogiri as he
makes his way there he expects his army
of heteromorphs will follow behind him
he believes that he is now the leader of
movement that will follow him until the
end but when he turns around he realizes
that no one is following him anymore the
other heteromorphs decided to heed
Shoji's words and the side of the
doctors and nurses stop them in their
tracks spinner manages to reach the
place where kurogiri is being held but
when he arrives there he is alone well
not exactly alone because as spinner
screams out the name kurogiri present
Mike appears behind him and screams out
the name of his friend
shirakumo and as we are left to wonder
which name kurogiri will respond to
shirakumo or kurogiri the chapter comes
to an end and man this kurogiri mystery
just keeps getting more and more
interesting and I for one am glad that
we are finally heading towards some sort
of resolution this kurogiri plot Point
has been looming over us for a long time
and I am ready to see where it goes as I
mentioned in previous videos I believe
that kurogiri is a special nomu who was
created from a living body the body of
oboro shirakumo rather than from a
corpse obero was severely injured by
Falling Rubble during a villain fight
and he was later declared dead but we
know who loves working at hospital
morgues and using those very places for
his experiments the infamous Dr ujiko
the doctor who works directly under all
for one so I believe that ujiko faked
obero's death so that he could use his
injured but still alive body for an
experiment and the result of that
experiment is the creature we know today
as kurogiri kurogiri is so highly
intelligent because he was made from a
living human and this means that the
human is still in there somewhere I also
believe that the villains will succeed
in releasing kurogiri and that kurogiri
will end up free
all for one from his floating prison at
the UA I believe this because let's face
it this is a Shonen and everyone wants
to see the ultimate villain in the story
fighting the main hero of the story at
full power and the only way that
shikiraki Sasha over one can really
reach his full power is if he regained
the ability to use all of his many
quirks at the same time though I do
believe that oboroshirakumo will
eventually reawaken within kurogiri and
that he may even play a part in
ultimately defeating all for one and
that brings me to the other big topic
that I want to talk about and that a lot
of you guys wanted me to talk about
judging by the comments on my previous
video there are of course a ton of
theories out there about the true
identity of deku's dad and why he has
been absent from the story this entire
time one theory is actually directly
connected to kurogiri and this was
actually pointed out in the comments to
my previous mha video this Theory states
that deku's Dad was actually turned into
a nomu just like kurogiri this means
that deku's Dad is still alive he's not
a corpse but he was turned into a living
normal like kurogiri and of course this
means that he was turned into a villain
against his will and he will eventually
make an appearance and the heroes might
even have to fight him but on the bright
side if he really is a living person who
was made into a nomu like kurogiri then
he will also be able to eventually
awaken just like obero shirakumo this
Theory doesn't necessarily explain why
Deku and his mother seem to think that
Hisashi midoriya is perfectly fine and
just working abroad although if he
really is a nomu who is under the
control of all for one then I guess all
for one could be manipulating him into
calling his family and telling them that
he's working abroad and that everything
is fine and meanwhile he's out there on
the streets committing villainous acts
on behalf of all for one personally I do
like this idea that deku's father could
be a nomu or a heteromorph or something
along those lines because it means that
he could have been right there hiding in
plain sight all along but we just never
realized who he really was I like this
because any theory for hisashi's
identity has to explain his extended
absence and family situation again based
on everything we know he and inko are
not estranged he did not abandon his
wife and son he is not dead he is not in
jail or anything along those lines Deku
and inko seemed to believe that he is
fine and still part of their family and
he's just working abroad but if that
really is the case then how come we
never see him how come he never comes to
visit or how come he doesn't at least
call his son and wife the world of mha
features modern technology like phones
and airplane travel so it's not like he
says she can't take a plane and come
visit his family because he has to
travel in a sailboat for six months if
he wants to see them I mean I guess
technically deku's Dad could have been
visiting and calling his family all
along it just always happens off screen
and no one ever mentions it in any way
but that would be pretty bad writing
with so many lingering questions about
deku's Dad and with his absence being
such a glaring and obvious part of the
story to say he's been around all along
just off screen and no one ever seems to
mention it would be a pretty massive
cop-out so I choose to believe that he
really hasn't been around and that there
is a very good reason for this I also
believe that the real reason is dark and
pretty effed up because that makes a lot
more sense he may have a very dangerous
Quirk and he doesn't want to be around
his family for their safety or he may be
a heteromorph and he avoids his family
because he doesn't want to expose them
to discrimination or as I mentioned
earlier he was turned into a nomu and is
being manipulated by All For One deku's
dad being a villain has been a very
popular theory for a long time but if he
really is one then I don't think that he
would become one willingly the kind of
man who would marry inko and raise a kid
like Deku is just not the kind of man
who would willingly become a Villain at
least not in my opinion but to be fair
you never know with how much horikoshi
loves Star Wars and with how blatantly
he references Star Wars even when those
references are way too on the nose and
even distracting from the emotional
moments in the story I honestly wouldn't
be surprised if fall for one really
turned out to be deku's dad and their
relationship ended up being a tribute to
the story of Luke and Darth Vader this
is also a really popular Theory probably
the most popular Theory when it comes to
deku's Dad but if this did turn out to
be the case it would mean that all for
one had successfully manipulated both
inko and Deku for like decades and I
mean that would be pretty wild
personally I think they are both too
smart for that but we'll have to wait
and see again if deku's Dad is a villain
of some sort I think he became one
unwillingly and I think that his absence
could be related to his Quirk and his
appearance and to the fact that he wants
to protect Deku and inko the story's
current focus on heteromorphs may be
hinting that deku's dad was a powerful
mutant type Quirk user and the next few
chapters and the situation with kurogiri
could provide the perfect setup for the
long-awaited Deku dad reveal what do you
guys think is kurogiri about to awaken
and help all for one or is shirakumo
going to take over is deku's Father a
heteromorph is he a nomu could he be a
villain could he be all for one finally
how will the final clash between good
and evil end and will kurogiri or maybe
shirakumo play an important part in it
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this mha
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second but
it helps me out a lot with that YouTube
algorithm and if you are part of the
over 50 percent of people who watch this
channel but are not subscribed do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar big thank you
to all of our anime outpro patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thanks you to trucker Tim a
disciple of Lord twigo himself and I
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons including Alpha Sigma Pate heffa
The Toasted Chi Cory McGowan own Taylor
and Anime s code M finally thank you to
all of our other patrons including Pro
Hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh Angel Cruz Alicia Octor Fatboy
games kaido might be a duck olivania
Sandy and the school bus if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon or by becoming a channel
member as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys